This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。100%真人制作。2%。当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数比例只有2%. 我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身意识以及抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。名字就是“2”这个数字，可在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方找到它。欢迎来到《Look Back at It》播客。从1979年开始，对当时的我和我来说，那是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每期节目中，我们会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着去理解我们是如何挺过那段时光的。和我们的朋友、喜剧同仁以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那确实是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们喜爱的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行坦诚的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实并不安全，但你是在和一个懂行的有资质的专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你非得这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生了一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人的遭遇。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everybody.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeart广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好。
Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners. Wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode. as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, we are talking about an episode that was requested by so many of you after an episode I did, maybe a year ago even, on how to have better conversations. And in that episode, I alluded to this idea of different kind of communication types,
欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到本播客。新听众，老听众。无论你身处世界的哪个角落，非常高兴你能回来收听另一期节目。正如我们当然要剖析我们的20多岁心理学。今天，我们要讨论的是在许多人强烈要求下制作的一期节目，那是在我大约一年前做过一期关于如何进行更好对话的节目之后。在那期节目中，我暗示了不同沟通类型的想法，
one of them being an assertive communicator. And so in this episode, I want to circle back. on to that. I want to circle back to this idea and talk about how you can be an assertive communicator. How can someone become someone who is confident in what they have and confident in what they're saying using some pretty amazing principles of psychology? So many of you have asked, when is this episode coming? And I honestly kept putting it on the back burner and like delaying it for whatever reason. But this week, I don't know what it was. It really felt like, the week to finally break it down.
其中之一就是果断的沟通者。所以在这一期里，我想回过头来。谈谈这个。我想回到这个话题，聊聊如何成为一个果断的沟通者。如何运用一些非常棒的心理学原理，让自己变得对自己的所有充满自信、对所说的话充满自信？你们中有很多人问，这期节目什么时候播出？说实话，我一直把它搁置一旁，由于各种原因一再推迟。但本周，我不知道为什么。这真的感觉像是一周，终于把它剖析清楚了。
So today, we're going to go through my five tips to be an assertive communicator, but also just a convincing, persuasive communicator in general. It's so interesting to me because we are never really taught how to be persuasive or how to ask for what we want in a way that will actually get us, what we want but also not frustrate people or make someone angry or upset. Sure, you know, maybe we did public speaking in high school. Maybe you did like debating and you had to get up and give a speech. But from my memory, when I did those things, you would kind of get up and do it and then they would grade you on the skills you already had without really giving you an opportunity
所以今天，我们将讲解我关于如何成为一个果断的沟通者的五个建议，同时也包括如何成为一个普遍具有说服力、令人信服的沟通者。这对我来说太有趣了，因为我们从来没有真正被教导过如何去说服别人，或者如何以一种真正能让我们如愿以偿、但又不会让人沮丧、生气或心烦的方式来索取我们想要的东西。当然，你知道，也许我们在高中时上过公开演讲课。也许你参加过辩论赛，不得不站起来发表一番演讲。但在我的记忆中，当我做这些事情时，你基本上就是站起来讲，然后他们会根据你原本就有的技能给你打分，却没有真正给你提供一个机会
to improve. Like I cannot actually remember anyone giving me legitimate tips. or a course. It was just being judged on like your preexisting ability and that preexisting ability how we communicate is largely formed by our parents, how they communicated, what their professions were, your innate confidence level, but being in a sort of communicator, it can be taught. It is not just for people who are inherently self-assured. It's also not just for extroverts either. It's for people who are introverts. It's for people who are shy. It's for people who are people pleases. And it's a really valuable skill to have. I think it's one of those skills that should probably be mandatory. I always think that in high school, we need to have like an intro to life
去提升自己。就像我真的记不起任何人给我过合理的建议。或是一门课程。这只是在评判你原本具备的能力，而这种原本具备的能力——我们如何沟通——在很大程度上是由我们的父母、他们的沟通方式、他们的职业、你天生的自信水平决定的，但是做一个果断的沟通者，它是可以被教授的。它不仅适用于那些天生自信的人。它也不仅仅适用于外向的人。它适合内向的人。它适合害羞的人。它适合讨好型人格的人。这是一个非常宝贵的技能。我认为这是那种应该被列为必修课的技能之一。我总是觉得，在高中里，我们需要开设一门类似生活导论
101 course. And in that course, you know, you should learn about taxes. You should learn about how to find a good mechanic, how to set boundaries, financial literacy. And I think you should also learn how to be an assertive communicator. There is not a single professor. that does not require it. And recent research that I was finding when I was investigating this topic has also discovered that being an assertive communicator, it doesn't just help relationships, it doesn't just help you in your career, obviously. It also makes you less stressed. It reduces cortisol arousal. It makes you healthier as an individual. So I'm going to give you five scientifically founded and psychologically backed tips to help you not feel ashamed for asking for what you
101的课程。在那门课里，你知道，你应该学习纳税。你应该学习如何找到一个好的机修工，如何设定界限，财务素养。而且我认为你还应该学习如何成为一个果断的沟通者。没有一个教授是不要求这一点的。而当我研究这个话题时发现的最新研究也表明，做一个果断的沟通者，它不仅有助于人际关系，显而易见，它不仅对你的职业生涯有帮助。它还能让你压力更小。它能降低皮质醇的激活水平。它能让你作为一个个体变得更健康。所以我将为你提供五个基于科学和心理学支持的建议，帮助你不再为索取自己想要的东西而感到羞耻，
want, how to make your preferences known, how to be someone who others will listen to, and just so much more. So without further ado, my lovely listeners, let's get into it. Let's begin by just really articulating what an assertive communicator is, because I have already alluded to the fact that it's likely different to what you are currently imagining. So research has largely agreed that that there are four different communication styles when it comes to tone and attitude. There is passive, there is aggressive, there is passive, aggressive, and there is assertive. Assertive sometimes in our minds can be confused with aggressive. We assume that it might come off as domineering, demanding, selfish, loud, arrogant,
如何让别人了解你的偏好，如何成为一个会被他人倾听的人，以及更多内容。废话不多说，我可爱的听众们，让我们切入正题吧。让我们首先来明确什么是果断的沟通者，因为我之前已经暗示过，这可能与你目前想象的不同。因此，研究大体上一致认为，在语气和态度方面存在四种不同的沟通风格。有被动的，有攻击性的，有被动攻击性的，还有果断的。有时在我们心中，果断可能会与攻击性混淆。我们认为它可能表现为专横、要求苛刻、自私、声音大、傲慢，
like, I want this, I want it now. If I don't get it, we will have issues. There is no compromise. Assertive communication really means that you advocate for yourself. don't self-silance and you try and get your point across honestly and with kindness but also self-assurance. It sounds like I'm going to invite you to see it from my perspective. It would help the team if you did this. I would appreciate if you didn't do that. I'm going to sit with this one. I'm going to think about this because I'm not feeling it currently. There is actually a lot of joy
比如，我想要这个，我现在就要。如果我得不到，我们就会有问题。没有妥协。果断的沟通实际上意味着你为自己发声。不自我禁声，并努力以诚实和善意以及自信的方式把你的观点表达清楚。听起来就像是我邀请你从我的角度来看待它。如果你这样做，对团队会有帮助。如果你不那样做，我会很感激。我要好好考虑一下。我要想想这个，因为我目前没有这种感觉。其实有很多快乐
and a lot of peace in being an assertive communicator because I think implicitly you understand that not everyone is going to agree with you. Not everyone is going to do what you want them to do, but you have made your point. You have communicated it and that sits really well with you. An assertive communicator is often times actually the most persuasive because they also don't use threats, they don't use guilt, they don't use demands to get their point across. They use inspiration, they use encouragement, they use personality. Another defining point is that they often rely on non-verbal cues that are very welcoming and which activate people's mirror neurons, which we're going to speak about in just a second, but the research has shown that this ability is really
成为一个果断的沟通者会带来很多平静，因为我认为你潜意识里明白，并不是每个人都会同意你的看法。并不是每个人都会按照你的意愿去做事，但你已经表达了你的观点。你已经传达了这一点，这让你感觉非常好。一个果断的沟通者通常实际上是最具说服力的，因为他们也不使用威胁、内疚或要求来表达他们的观点。他们使用启发、鼓励、个性。另一个决定性的特点是，他们经常依靠非常受欢迎的非语言线索，这些线索可以激活人们的镜像神经元，我们稍后会讨论这一点，但研究表明，这种能力确实
what makes a sort of communicator so persuasive. And they do things that people don't often think are persuasive. They speak slower. They also use more of their vocal range. Side note, this was quite an interesting piece of research that I discovered when I was looking into this, and it's that people with more empathy also tend to use more of their vocal range. And a paper from 2009 actually found that diagnosed psychopaths actually have a reduced vocal range. So their voice is more immovable. It doesn't flow. It doesn't go up and down. So there you go, a really interesting sign of both an assertive and empathetic person, but also communicator. They use their voice.
是什么让果断的沟通者如此具有说服力。他们会做一些人们通常不认为具有说服力的事情。他们说话更慢。他们还使用更多的音域。顺便说一句，这是我研究这个话题时发现的一个非常有趣的研究成果，那就是更有同理心的人往往也使用更多的音域。2009年的一篇论文实际上发现，被诊断为精神病态的人实际上音域较窄。所以他们的声音更不可动摇。它不流畅。它不会上下起伏。所以你看，这不仅是一个果断和富有同理心的人的一个非常有趣的标志，也是一个沟通者的标志。他们运用自己的声音。
They use it almost like an instrument, something that flows and surrounds people. And I really don't think that being assertive and being empathetic is something that can be separated. They actually go hand in hand. Let's talk about the other three types of communicators. Aggressive communicators, they are forceful, they are immovable. They interrupt. they yell, they use threats, they find it hard to be silent, they also use less eye contact. Passive communicators are often very indirect and submissive.
他们几乎把它当成一件乐器，一种流动并包围人们的东西。我真的认为果断和富有同理心是密不可分的。它们实际上是齐头并进的。让我们来谈谈其他三种类型的沟通者。攻击型沟通者，他们强硬，他们不可动摇。他们打断别人。他们大喊大叫，他们使用威胁，他们觉得很难保持沉默，他们也较少进行眼神交流。被动型沟通者通常非常间接和顺从。
They really just avoid expressing their needs and they downplay their feelings and they avoid conflict. It's also highly associated with people who are conflict averse or who are chronic people pleases, chronic apologizes as well, which we actually have an episode about coming up very, very soon. And finally, passive aggressive of communicators. This is the least successful communicator. And that's because it combines the worst aspects of the two previous communication stars. They are often hostile. They are indirect. They don't say what they mean. They rely heavily on silence, the silent treatment, and also guilt to support their unrealistic demands. So those are the four communication styles and we often begin to develop our
他们真的只是避免表达自己的需求，他们淡化自己的感受，并且回避冲突。这也高度关联于那些逃避冲突的人，或者是长期讨好型人格、长期习惯性道歉的人，我们其实很快就会有一期关于这个的节目。最后是被动攻击型沟通者。这是最不成功的沟通者。这是因为结合了前两种沟通风格最糟糕的方面。他们通常充满敌意。他们是间接的。他们言不由衷。他们严重依赖沉默，冷暴力，以及内疚来支撑他们不切实际的要求。这就是这四种沟通风格，而我们通常开始发展我们的
communication style, not through an intentional effort, but through outside influence. So family, culture, early experiences, our environment, which is actually a good thing. I know it sounds like, oh, none of this is within my control, but it also means that a lot of it is environmental, so it can be changed. So without further ado, let's talk about how we can change them. Let's talk about those five tips I spoke about before. So my first tip for becoming an assertive communicator, tip one is that assertive communicators know how to value silence more than their words. And it doesn't mean they use the silent treatment. It means they appreciate the pause.
沟通风格，不是通过有意识的努力，而是通过外部影响。比如家庭、文化、早期经历、我们的环境，这其实是一件好事。我知道这听起来好像，哦，这一切都不在我的控制之内，但这也意味着其中很大一部分是环境因素，所以它是可以改变的。废话不多说，让我们来谈谈如何改变它们。让我们来谈谈我之前提到的那五个建议。因此，我成为果断沟通者的第一个建议，建议一是果断的沟通者懂得比自己的言语更珍视沉默。这并不意味着他们使用冷暴力。这意味着他们懂得欣赏停顿。
Pausing in a conversation actually brings you back into control. Now, I don't think the conversations are necessarily like a battlefield for being in charge and it's like this huge conflict. But a pause, I think, brings you back into control over yourself, which is what's really a here. Have you ever, I don't know, have you ever had that experience of being in a really important conversation with someone and you find you just can't stop talking? Like words are just spilling out of your mouth before you can even think of them. Like there is no, there's nothing between your brain and the words coming out of your mouth. I remember doing this really important interview when I was 20. And as soon as one of the interviewers asked me a question, like I just said the first thing that I
在对话中停顿实际上能让你重新掌控局面。现在，我不认为对话本质上就像争夺主导地位的战场，或者像这种巨大的冲突。但我觉得，停顿能让你重新掌控自己，这才是真正重要的事情。你有没有过这样的经历，我不知道，你有没有过那种与某人进行非常重要对话的经历，而你发现自己就是停不下来？就像话语从你嘴里倾泻而出，甚至在你思考它们之前。就像没有，你的大脑和从你嘴里说出来的话之间没有任何阻碍。我记得当我20岁时进行过一次非常重要的面试。当其中一位面试官问我问题时，就像我直接说出了我的第一反应
was thinking and it normally wasn't the best thing. And I think if I had just learnt the power of the two second pause, it would have had two really important effects. A, it would have shown the interviewers that I was actually considering their question a little bit. And B, I would have answered better. I think a lot of us are innately very afraid of silence in a conversation, but pausing really just ensures that you say what you mean. And there's this other part of that as well, pauses, silence, that is where meaning takes hold. It is really hard to know what someone really means or is saying in a conversation if you are constantly talking and having to make these assessments on the fly. This is why I think we typically only fully realize what someone was actually saying
想到的，而且通常不是最好的答案。我想如果我当时学会了停顿两秒钟的力量，它会产生两个非常重要的效果。A，它会向面试官表明我其实是在认真思考他们的问题。B，我会回答得更好。我认为我们中的很多人天生对对话中的沉默感到非常害怕，但停顿确实能确保你言之有物。此外还有另一个部分，停顿，沉默，那是意义扎根的地方。如果你一直在说话，并且不得不当场做出这些评估，你就很难知道别人在谈话中真正意味着什么或在说什么。这就是为什么我认为我们通常只有在对话结束之后，才真正意识到别人刚才对我们说了什么。有时这真的很沮丧，因为突然间你有了所有最好的反驳，比如你想到了所有你希望自己说过的话。
to us after a conversation is over. And sometimes that's really frustrating because suddenly like you have all your best comebacks, like you think of all the things that you wish you had said. pauses are so effective in that sense because you can really hear the things that aren't being said. That's what silence does. And it also says, I'm comfortable with silence because I'm comfortable with myself, which is a particularly powerful message that you want to send if you're trying to be assertive and you're trying to advocate for yourself. So here's how to apply this practically.
从这个意义上说，停顿是非常有效的，因为你可以真正听到那些没有被说出来的话。这就是沉默的作用。它也传达出：我习惯沉默，因为我对自己感到舒适。如果你想表现得果断并为自己发声，这是一个特别强大的信息。所以具体该如何应用呢。
When you feel yourself getting very, maybe running away with your thoughts, thoughts or you're reaching dead ends or you feel like you're losing control of the conversation. Pause for three seconds before every sentence, before you say anything. Or you can create a physical cue that you need to do first before you speak. I was reading this really amazing book recently. I cannot remember the name. But the author talks about how she always nods to her twice before replying to someone. So someone will say something to her and she'll go, and then she'll reply.
当你觉得自己可能，思绪飞扬，或者走入死胡同，或者觉得你正在失去对话的控制时。在每个句子之前，在你开口说任何话之前，停顿三秒钟。或者你可以在说话前先做一个你需要做的身体动作。我最近在读一本非常棒的书。我记不清书名了。但作者谈到了她在回答别人之前总是对对方点两次头。所以别人会对她说些什么，她会说，然后她会回答。
because it positively reinforces that she's listening, but it also allows her to reassess her words. Assertive communicators, they know the power of the pores. Tip number two. Learn how to regulate your body. It is just as important as what you have to say. Your body language is language. It is saying something.
因为这起到了积极的强化作用，表明她在倾听，但这也让她能够重新评估自己的言辞。果断的沟通者，他们懂得停顿的力量。建议之二。学会调节你的身体。这与你要说的话同样重要。你的肢体语言就是语言。它在表达某些东西。
And if you feel like you're about to burst out of your skin or there is this hidden tension that you can't, control most of the time that will come across and it can make you seem aggressive or anxious which could be interpreted as passive neither of which we want we're going to regulate that before you go into a conversation or you go to do a speech or whatever it is I want you to do this exercise with me that I personally use this is the exact exercise I do before every speech every podcast recording, every live show, it is an excellent way to regulate your body. So you stand up, you let your arms go completely slack, you let your shoulders fall as far as they want to,
如果你觉得自己快要崩溃了，或者有一种你无法控制的内在紧张感，大多数时候这会表现出来，这会让你显得具有攻击性或焦虑，而这可能会被解读为被动，这两者都不是我们想要的，我们要在你进入对话、进行演讲或做任何事情之前调节好状态。我希望你和我一起做这个我自己用的练习，这是我每次演讲、每次播客录制、每场现场演出前做的确切练习，这是调节身体的绝佳方法。所以你站起来，让双臂完全放松下垂，让双肩自然下垂，垂到它们想去的地方，
as far as they can without any effort. Then I want you to notice your eyebrows, notice your forehead, release any tension, consciously release the muscles around your mouth, around your eyes, just let them go as well. And I want you to sway. gently from side to side, maybe hum to yourself, keep your eyes closed, roll your shoulders back, then forward, take three deep breaths and open your eyes. This exercise works because of the principles of progressive relaxation. It makes you feel more in touch with your body. It means that you can regulate it. It means that you have a baseline level of stability, but that ritual is also equally soothing. So it gets you really in the headspace. So this is the pre-communication exercise.
尽它们所能自然下垂，不需要任何力气。然后我希望你注意你的眉毛，注意你的额头，释放任何紧张感，有意识地放松你嘴巴周围、眼睛周围的肌肉，也让它们放松。我希望你轻轻地。左右摇晃，也许对自己哼唱，闭上眼睛，向后转动肩膀，然后向前，深呼吸三次，然后睁开眼睛。这个练习之所以有效，是因为渐进式放松的原理。它让你感觉更能掌控自己的身体。这意味着你可以调节它。这意味着你拥有一个基准水平的稳定性，但这种仪式同样具有舒缓作用。所以它能让你真正进入状态。所以这是沟通前的练习。
This is the before. But when it comes to actually communicating and using your body language in an effective way during a conversation, we really need to talk about this expert. His name is David Phillips. And he has spent literally years analyzing over 5,000 successful public speakers. and he has noticed that there is a few things that they really do, and which you might not notice they're doing, but you are nonetheless being influenced by. So the first thing they do is that they stop themselves from hunching. They keep their shoulders back.
这是事前准备。但当谈到实际沟通并在对话中以有效的方式运用你的肢体语言时，我们真的需要谈谈这位专家。他的名叫大卫·菲利普斯。他花了数年时间分析了5000多名成功的公众演讲者。他注意到他们确实做了一些事情，而你可能没有注意到他们在这样做，但你不可避免地受到了影响。所以他们做的第一件事就是阻止自己驼背。他们保持双肩后展。
They open up their body. It invites people in. They raise their chin. They also lean towards whoever they're speaking to, which actually gives the impression of confidence and feeling relaxed, as opposed to tension and leaning away. If you think about it in nature, but if you're turning away from someone,
他们敞开身体。这邀请人们走近。他们抬起下巴。他们还会向他们正在说话的人倾斜，这实际上给人一种自信和放松的感觉，而不是紧张和退缩。如果你在自然界中想想，但如果你背对着某人，
if you're moving away from them, you feel threatened. If you're leaning towards them, you feel safe and that makes someone else feel safe. Two other things that they do, the first thing is that successful assertive communicators tilt their head. Imagine someone saying something to you that's really, really sad and really, really awful.
如果你从他们身边移开，你会感到受到威胁。如果你向他们倾斜，你会感到安全，这也会让别人感到安全。他们做的另外两件事，第一件事是，成功的果断沟通者会倾斜他们的头部。想象一下有人对你说了非常非常悲伤、非常非常糟糕的事情。
Like, I don't know, I have cancer or my boyfriend just broke up with me. You immediately go for the head tilt. Oh, I'm so sorry. Oh, that's so awful. Because for some reason, it's an indicator of empathy. It's a silent way of displaying, like, I'm thinking about you. I care about you.
比如，我不知道，我得了癌症或者我男朋友刚和我分手。你马上就会歪头。哦，我很抱歉。哦，那太糟糕了。因为某种原因，这是同理心的指标。这是一种无声的方式，展示出：我在想着你。我关心你。
Now, the final thing that assertive communicators do that David Phillips noticed was something called a Duchenne smile. So a Deschen smile is a type of genuine grin that moves somebody's entire face, not just their mouth. So this kind of smile that was discovered, or I should say, first named by a friend neurologist called Giuliamu Duchenne back in the mid-19th century. And he basically realized, just through interacting with people, there are two kinds of smiles. The Duchenne smile, the non-Duchens smile. One involves the use of all the muscles in your face, in your forehead, around your eyes,
现在，大卫·菲利普斯注意到的果断沟通者的最后一件事是一种被称为杜兴微笑的微笑。所以杜兴微笑是一种真诚的露齿笑，它会调动一个人整张脸，而不仅仅是嘴巴。所以这种微笑是由19世纪中叶一位名叫朱利安·杜兴的神经学家发现的，或者我应该说最早命名的。他基本上意识到，仅仅通过与人交往，有两种微笑。杜兴微笑，非杜兴微笑。一种涉及面部所有肌肉的运用，包括额头、眼睛周围、
around your mouth. The other smile, the non-Duchens smile, just uses your mouth. It's a very inauthentic kind of smile, a very coy kind of smile. If you think about the Mona Lisa, best example of a non-Duchin smile. But what they have found after the naming of this smile is that people who present a Duchenne smile, it serves a really important function. It makes you seem more friendly. It makes you more likable. People are more likely to agree with you. And it just makes you seem like a more assertive kind person. The mood from this also really shifts. So you may notice that once you perform a Duchenne smile, the other person smiles back at you. And this is the work of what we call mirror neurons.
嘴巴周围。另一种微笑，非杜兴微笑，只动用了嘴巴。这是一种非常不真实的微笑，一种非常羞涩的微笑。如果你想想蒙娜丽莎，这就是非杜兴微笑的最佳例子。但在这类微笑命名之后，人们发现，展现杜兴微笑的人具有非常重要的功能。它让你看起来更友好。它让你更讨人喜欢。人们更有可能同意你的观点。它只是让你看起来像一个更果断、更善良的人。这种情绪也随之发生了真正的转变。所以你可能会注意到，一旦你做出杜兴微笑，对方也会对你微笑。这就是我们所说的镜像神经元的运作结果。
So we talked about this before. Mirror neurons, they're a specific kind of brain cell that basically is essential for empathy. And what it does is when someone else performs an action to you, this part of your brain, these cells automatically are firing. and it essentially wants to perform that action back to that person. Someone smiles, you find yourself smiling. Someone looks disgusted, you find yourself also looking disgusted. It's this kind of weird neurological way that we feel connected and bonded to each other through that exchange of behaviours.
所以我们之前讨论过这个。镜像神经元是特定的一种脑细胞，对同理心基本上至关重要。它的作用是，当别人对你做出某种行为时，你大脑的这部分、这些细胞会自动被激活。它基本上想要对那个人做出同样的反应。别人笑了，你发现自己也在笑。别人看起来很厌恶，你发现自己也看起来很厌恶。这是一种奇怪的神经学方式，通过行为的交流，我们感到彼此相连和羁绊。
And so if you want to really be assertive and if you want to be convincing, what you have to do is perform the kind of body language that you think or you wish someone was going to perform back to you. What's the kind of environment, the physical environment that you want associated with this conversation? The easiest way to create that is to perform those behaviors first and kind of lead by example. So this is your reminder. Your words really do matter, but your body language, what your body is saying might just matter more. Okay, we are going to take a short break, but when we return, I have three final tips for you, so stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
所以，如果你真的想表现得果断，如果你想具有说服力，你必须表现出你认为或希望别人对你做出的那种肢体语言。你希望与这场对话相关的环境、物理环境是什么样的？营造这种环境最简单的方法就是首先表现出这些行为，并以身作则。所以这是对你的提醒。你的言语确实很重要，但你的肢体语言，你的身体在表达什么，可能更重要。好了，我们要稍作休息，但当我们回来时，我还有最后三个建议留给你，所以请继续收听。2%。当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人数比例只有2%。
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts. and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身意识以及抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家对话。以及更多内容，以看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更 healthier 的人。收听《2%》。
That's T-W-O-P-Cent on the I-H. Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends,
那是T-W-O-P-Cent，可在I-H-Heart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。每个男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，千万不要惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也千万不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这新一季的《女朋友们》中，
Oh my God, this is the same man. a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target.
天哪，这就是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉像被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。所以她们把事情掌握在自己手中。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。
He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Remember when Diana Ross double-taped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
他会得到他应得的。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。可在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA上给小金的胸部贴了两层胶带吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill,
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟一个小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每期节目中，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何挺过那段时光的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, Yeah, yeah, literally. But just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed,
畅谈80年代的可卡因。需要明确的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我一整天都乐意聊可卡因，是的，是的，真的。但为了让你们知道。我的意思是，此时此刻，马克，这是我们讨论的第二集，
correct. So I'm starting to see there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
对。所以我开始发现这是一条贯穿线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆上台面了。谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast. Learn the hard way.
是的。对我和美国历史上的黑人来说，这是最重要的一年之一。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客。Learn the Hard Way。
with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the
我是你的主持人，你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的正是。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某个事物时，
thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and loss. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth,
我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这个事物。而我们还在继续追逐，却不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们盯着记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，
or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
还是说你成为一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人。和我，科尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的iHeart Radio应用。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。
Okay, we're talking about the five ways to transform yourself into an assertive communicator. Tip number three, make it about you. If you want something done or you want to convince someone of some kind of point, it's actually not about them. This is a conversation for you. This is your attempt to get your point across. This is you communicating something that you value. So the way that you can make it about you is that, of course, we can do things. things like use eye statements, I feel, I expected, I assumed, I saw.
好的，我们正在讨论将自己转变为果断沟通者的五种方法。建议三，以自我为中心。如果你想把事情做好，或者你想说服别人接受某种观点，其实这与他们无关。这是属于你的对话。这是你表达观点、传达你所珍视事物的尝试。所以，以自我为中心的方式，当然，我们可以做一些事情。
We also want to switch from people pleasing to something called self-authorship. Self-authorship is not demanding. It just works to articulate our perspective, our self-concept by essentially using phrases that reflect our self-definition. And it uses these phrases as a way to say, hey, humanize me, know that I'm my own in person, know that I respect myself, but I want to work with you on that. So some of the statements that activate a self-authorship perspective or the kind of language that we would want to be using things like, this doesn't align with how I want to work. I've thought about it and I'm not
比如使用“我”开头的陈述，我觉得、我预计、我假设、我看到。我们还希望从迎合他人转变为所谓的自我署名。自我署名并不是提出要求。它只是致力于通过本质上使用反映我们自我定义的短语来阐明我们的视角、我们的自我概念。它使用这些短语作为一种方式来表达：嘿，请把我看作一个人，知道我是我自己的独立个体，知道我尊重自己，但我想在这件事上与你合作。因此，一些能够激活自我署名视角的陈述，或者我们想要使用的语言类型，比如：这与我的工作方式不符。我考虑过了，我不会
choosing what feels right for me. So I'm going to change my mind. I really value your perspective, but I've thought about what this means for me and it doesn't actually meet my needs. Something you may notice about these kind of statements, they imply self-reflection, not just an opinion, not just a guess. Like, they are saying, I have done deep thinking, I'm not just immediately dismissing you. And they also contain an essential boundary. They're saying, thank you, but no, thank you. It is very hard to argue with someone when what they're expressing is personal to them.
选择感觉不对的事情。所以我要改变主意。我非常重视你的观点，但我考虑了这对我的意义，它实际上并没有满足我的需求。关于这类陈述，你可能会注意到的一点是，它们暗示了自我反思，而不仅仅是一个观点，不只是一个猜测。就像，它们在说，我已经进行了深刻的思考，我不是在立刻敷衍你。它们还包含了一个必不可少的界限。它们在说，谢谢，但不用了。当一个人表达的内容对他们来说是私人的时，是很难与之争论的。
And it's very hard to implicitly say, I don't agree, because it comes off as an insult to our personhood if we frame things in a way of self-authorship. Like, imagine someone saying, I'm choosing what feels right for me. And you saying, well, I don't like that. I disagree. It feels unnatural. It makes the other person seem like the asshole. So if you want to be more assertive, make statements like this part of your vocabulary.
而且很难潜意识地说“我不同意”，因为如果我们以自我署名的方式来构建事物，这会被视为对我们人格的侮辱。就像，想象有人说，我选择符合我感觉的事情。而你说，嗯，我不喜欢那样。我不同意。这感觉很不自然。这会让对方看起来像个混蛋。因此，如果你想变得更果断，就把这样的陈述变成你词汇的一部分。
I'm going to give you a few other examples because I feel like once you hear them being said, it's easier to say them themselves. Here are some examples. This may disappoint you, but it's what I need to do. I've spent time reflecting, and this is an important boundary for me. It's really important for me to follow through on what I value. I respect your opinion, but I am standing by my choice. Can you just see how powerful these are? They're not insulting.
我再给你几个例子，因为我觉得一旦你听到它们被说出来，自己说出口就会更容易。以下是一些例子。这可能会让你失望，但这是我需要做的。我花时间进行了反思，对我来说这是一个重要的界限。坚持我所珍视的东西对我很重要。我尊重你的意见，但我坚持我的选择。你能看出这些有多强大吗？它们不是侮辱性的。
They're not angry. They're just assertive. these statements are so measured. They're also quite personal. They're quite intimate because you're kind of letting someone know your core values. You're letting someone observe your thought process. And it shows that, you know, well, you're not going to be forced to act in a way that is against your values because you think about them and you care about them deeply.
它们并不生气。它们只是果断。这些陈述非常有分寸。它们也相当个人化。它们相当亲密，因为你有点让别人知道了你的核心价值观。你让别人观察你的思考过程。这表明，你知道，嗯，你不会被迫以违背你价值观的方式行事，因为你考虑过它们并且深深地关心它们。
But you're also not going to get mad and argue about it either. Like this is not up for discussion. So using self-oriented. Authorship language, incredibly effective. Tip number four, visualize. If you want to be in a set of communicator, visualize how you want the conversation to go, visualize how you're going to handle yourself,
但你也不会因此生气并与之争论——这无可商榷。因此，使用自我导向的署名语言，非常有效。建议之四，可视化。如果你想成为一个果断的沟通者，可视化你希望对话如何进行，可视化你将如何掌控自己，
visualize the best communicator you know, try and embody them, visualize how you want the other person to react. Visualization, especially if you're quite anxious when you talk to others, it works because the brain often can't distinguish between imagination and reality. It gets us in a lot of trouble sometimes. This is a case where it really works in our favor.
可视化你认识的最好的沟通者，试着去体现他们，可视化你希望对方如何反应。可视化，特别是如果你在与他人交谈时相当焦虑，之所以有效，是因为大脑往往无法区分想象和现实。这有时给我们带来很多麻烦。这是一个确实对我们有利的案例。
When you vividly picture yourself having a conversation and you are calm and you are clear and you are confident, you activate the same neural pathways that would be firing if you are actually doing it. And this kind of mental rehearsal helps reduce anxiety. It increases a sense of preparedness. It makes the situation also feel more familiar. and we know that a lot of the times anxiety is just coming from a fear of uncertainty. So if it feels certain in your mind by thinking about it beforehand, you'll feel more certain
当你生动地想象自己进行对话，并且你保持冷静、清晰和自信时，你会激活与实际这样做时相同的神经通路。这种心理排练有助于减少焦虑。它增加了准备感。这也让情况感觉更熟悉。我们知道，很多时候焦虑只是来自于对不确定性的恐惧。因此，如果你通过事先思考在心中确定了这一点，你就会在当下感到更加确定。
in the moment. There is an amazing study from 2016 and it's titled imagining success and the effectiveness of imagery that essentially shows that when you do these kinds of exercises, when you imagine winning, when you imagine an outcome you want, that programming, that's what you're doing, you're programming your mind, it improves performance and it improved the likelihood of participants in this case winning their tennis match. So it could also improve the likelihood of you coming across in a way that is confident and true to what you want to say and what you believe in. You know, you and your brain have a two-way relationship. Even if you have a baseline level of anxiety around
有一项2016年的惊人研究，题为《想象成功与意象的有效性》，该研究基本上表明，当你做这类练习时，当你想象获胜时，当你想象你想要的结果时，这种编程——这就是你正在做的，你在给你的大脑编程——可以提高表现，并提高了参与者（在本案中）赢得网球比赛的可能性。它还可以提高你以一种自信且忠于你想说的话和你的信仰的方式展现自己的可能性。你知道，你和你的大脑有一种双向关系。即使你对果断表达有一种基准水平的焦虑，你对自己说的话、对大脑说的话确实很重要，并且会有所帮助。这部分的另一部分是把自己想象成你钦佩的人并体现你认为他们会表现出的样子。想想你认为是一个非常沉着、果断的演讲者的人。在你的大脑中认真想想。你仰慕谁？在我踏入任何我要发言或必须站在人们面前的空间之前，我总是想象的人是米歇尔·奥巴马。她非常有风度。她很有正直感，说话非常清晰，我只是想，你知道，如果我走进一个让我感到压力的情况，她会怎么处理？她会用什么词？她什么时候会停顿？她会如何保持自己？我称之为“大师级英雄效应”，我想它还有另一个名字，但
being assertive, what you say to yourself, what you say to your brain does matter and will help. Another part of this imagining yourself as somebody you admire and embodying how you think they would behave. Think about someone who you think is a really composed, assertive speaker. Really think about it in your brain. Who do you look up to? The person I always imagine before I step into any space where I'm speaking or where I have to get up in front of people is Michelle Obama. Like she has so much poise. She is so much integrity she speaks so clearly and I just think you know how would she handle this if I'm walking into a situation that is stressing me out what words would she use when would she pause how would she hold herself I call it the masterful hero effect I think it has another term but
保持坚定，你对自己说的话，你对大脑说的话确实很重要，而且会有所帮助。这其中的另一个部分是，把自己想象成你钦佩的人，并具象化他们会如何行事。想想一个你认为非常沉着、坚定的演讲者。在脑海中好好想想。你崇拜谁？在我走进任何需要演讲或必须站到众人面前的空间之前，我脑海中总是浮现的那个人是米歇尔·奥巴马。她举止优雅，坚守正直，说话清晰明了，我想，如果我正步入一个让我感到压力的情境，她会如何处理？她会用什么词？她会在什么时候停顿？她会如何保持仪态？我称之为“大师级英雄效应”，我想它还有另一个称呼，不过
for me masterful hero effect and it really works you know if people you admire can shape our behavior through what we buy and what we consume and how we dress and what books we read or music we listen to, if they can influence us that way, they can also shape our speaking behavior and how we assert ourselves because they set an example. I think having an example of a person like this also calms the innate people pleasing part of me, at least, that is really imagining the world collapsing and relationships ceasing to exist if I ever set a real boundary. If I ever said, I'm not okay with that. That's a big fear.
对我而言，这种“大师级的英雄效应”真的很管用。你知道，如果你钦佩的人能够通过我们购买的物品、消费的东西、穿的衣服、读的书或听的音乐来塑造我们的行为，如果他们能以这种方式影响我们，他们也能塑造我们的说话方式以及我们如何坚持自我，因为他们树立了榜样。我认为，拥有这样一个榜样也能平息我内心深处那种天生的“讨好型人格”——至少当我真正去想象，如果我设立了真正的底线，世界就会崩溃、人际关系就会不复存在时，那种恐惧确实存在。如果我曾说过：“我对此感到不舒服。”那将是一个巨大的恐惧。
I think that's the main barrier to being an assertive communicator. What if people think that I'm an arseal? What if they don't want to be my friend? And so having that example of someone who is loud and clear and not afraid to express what they want, and yet still has successful, beautiful relationships just reinforces that. Perhaps this fear that being assertive is going to ruin friendships or partnerships for you is a myth your brain is trying to tell you for whatever reason. Sometimes actually relationships do need hard boundaries and they do need assertiveness.
我认为这是成为一个坚定沟通者的主要障碍。如果别人觉得我是个混蛋怎么办？如果他们不想和我交朋友怎么办？因此，拥有这样一个榜样——一个声音洪亮、思路清晰、不怕表达自己想要什么，却依然能拥有成功、美好关系的人——正好巩固了这一点。也许“坚定会毁了你的友谊或伴侣关系”这种恐惧，只是你大脑出于某种原因试图编造的一个神话。有时候，人际关系确实需要明确的底线，也确实需要坚定。
So you're not kind of like running around in the dark trying to figure out what someone else wants. It'd be so much easier if they just came out and said it. And I think we can all acknowledge that our lives would also be easier if sometimes we just swallowed the hard pill and just said what we really wanted and weren't afraid to upset people. Now, my lovely listeners, our final tip for this episode, possibly my favorite one, use flattery, flatter the person by personalizing your framing to make them seem superior. Let me explain this, because if it sounds like many people, I promise it isn't. The best way I can explain this is if you've ever heard a dog,
这样你就不用像在黑暗中摸索那样去猜别人想要什么了。如果他们能直接说出来，事情就会简单得多。我想我们都能承认，如果我们有时能咽下苦药，直接说出我们真正想要的东西，而不怕惹恼别人，我们的生活也会变得更轻松。好了，我可爱的听众们，本集的最后一条建议——可能也是我最喜欢的一条——就是使用奉承，通过个性化的措辞来吹捧对方，让他们显得高人一等。让我解释一下，因为如果听起来和很多人想的一样，我向我保证其实不然。我能解释这个的最佳方式是，如果你听过关于狗的说法，
you will know the easiest way to make them take medication, something that, you know, they typically don't enjoy, is to sneak it into something really, really tasty. So like my dog, she's like this, she will just refuse to eat her worming medication or her tick medication, but the moment it is in a piece of chicken, like she's all over it. We're going to do the same for our more difficult conversations with maybe the more difficult people in our lives or who we encounter. We're going to sneak what we want into the conversation using a metaphorical piece of chicken and hopefully finish up with our intended outcome. So how are we going to do this?
你就会知道，让它们吃药（你知道的，它们通常不喜欢的东西）最简单的方法，就是把药偷偷塞进非常非常美味的东西里。就像我的狗狗一样，她就是这样，她会拒绝吃驱虫药或防跳蚤药，但只要把它塞进一块鸡肉里，她就会立刻狼吞虎咽。我们要对生活中可能比较难对付的人，或者我们遇到的那些更棘手的对话采取同样的方法。我们要用一块“隐喻的鸡肉”，把我们想要的东西偷偷塞进对话中，并希望能达到我们预期的结果。那么我们要怎么做呢？
Essentially, what you're going to do is make someone feel like they already know what you're about to say and they already agree with it because they have already had. had the thought you've had, they've already considered it because they are superior. So phrases like this, you probably already know this, but I just want to make it really clear. I know you're probably already thinking this through, but I just want to share my perspective as well. What I love about you is how intuitive you are. So you've probably already picked up on the fact that, dot, dot, dot, dot. This is peak assertiveness. you are bringing someone onto your side, but still confidently making your point.
本质上，你要做的是让对方觉得他们已经知道你想说什么，并且他们已经同意了，因为他们已经有过你脑海中的想法，他们已经考虑过了，因为他们高人一等。所以可以用这样的句式：“你可能已经知道了，但我只想把它说清楚。”“我知道你可能已经在考虑这个了，但我只想分享一下我的视角。”“我最喜欢你的一点就是你非常有直觉，所以你可能已经注意到了……”这是极致的坚定。你把对方拉到了你这一边，但仍然自信地表达了你的观点。
Also, what I found is if someone wants to disagree with you or dismiss you or dismiss the second part of a statement, they also have to disagree with the first part of the statement as well, which their ego will probably prevent them from doing. So let me use one of those sentences just to illustrate this. I know you're really switched on, so this has probably already crossed your mind, but when you don't clean up after yourself, that means someone else has to do it. That first half of the sentence is crucial. I know you're really switched on.
此外，我发现如果有人想要反驳你、打消你的念头，或者否定你陈述的后半部分，他们也不得不同意你陈述的前半部分，而他们的自尊心大概会阻止他们这么做。让我用其中一个句子来举例说明这一点：“我知道你脑子转得很快，所以这可能已经在你脑海里闪现过了，但是当你自己用完东西不清理时，就意味着别人得去收拾。”这句话的前半部分至关重要：“我知道你脑子转得很快。”
This person isn't going to say, well, no, I'm not. I'm not actually that switched on. Because that's just kind of intuitive. They want to maintain their sense of pride and their sense of ego. And so by introducing a statement with something positive that they inherently will agree to,
这个人是不会说：“哦，不，我不是。我其实没那么机灵。”因为这有点违反直觉。他们想要维护自己的自尊心和骄傲感。因此，通过一个他们本能上就会赞同的正面陈述来引入话题，
it means that they agree with the entire thing. This tactic, the reason it works psychologically, because it actually taps into something called the Dunning Kruger effect. I spoke about this in my book a lot in the chapter on mistakes, but people really overestimate their competence and their abilities. So if you play into that and you tap into their desire to maintain their self-image as someone who is intelligent, competent, knowing, aware, intuitive, whatever it is. It's not that you trick them into agreeing with you, but you make it easier for
这意味着他们同意了整件事情。这个策略之所以在心理上起作用，是因为它实际上利用了一种叫做“邓宁-克鲁格效应”的现象。我在我的书中关于“错误”那一章里大量谈到过这一点，人们总是极高地估计自己的能力和水平。所以，如果你顺应这一点，利用他们想要把自己维持为“聪明、能干、懂行、有觉悟、有直觉”等形象的心理。这并不是说你在欺骗他们来同意你，而是你让他们更容易
them to agree with you. You lower the ego barrier by kind of opening the door and saying, well, you're already so much smarter than me. So come in. Come in and show me how it's done. I think it also makes people less defensive. You know, people don't want to have difficult conversations. I know I don't. So when you introduce it in a positive way, it also lessens the chance that either one of you is going to become upset, aggressive or agreeable. So those are my five tips. Let's do a quick refresh before I give you some rapid-fire bonus ones, but number one, know the power of the pause. Number two, regulate your body. Number three, make it about you. Number four, visualize. Number five, flattery. I deliberately in this didn't want to include
去同意你。你通过打开一扇门并说“哦，你本来就比我聪明得多，所以请进，请进来向我展示一下该怎么做”，从而降低了对方的自尊防线。我认为这也让人不那么具有防御心理。你知道的，人们都不想进行艰难的对话，我知道我也不想。所以当你用积极的方式引入时，也会降低你们双方变得心烦、好斗或争强好胜的可能性。这就是我的五个建议。在我给你一些快速的额外建议之前，让我们快速回顾一下：第一，了解停顿的力量；第二，调节你的身体；第三，关注你自己；第四，可视化；第五，奉承。我在这期节目中刻意不想包含
tips that maybe you had heard before. So apologies if these were things you already knew, especially the body language tip. I know a lot of people talk about that. I think we all have some clue of how powerful that is. But there were some tips I didn't include that are pretty common. And if you need a refresher, let's quickly go through them. Because I think any further ways that we can be assertive, anything that clicks with you, that's important. So remember to be direct but not harsh.
你可能以前听过的建议。所以如果这些是你已经知道的事情，尤其是肢体语言的建议，还请见谅。我知道很多人都在谈论这个。我想我们都对它的威力有所了解。但确实有一些很常见的建议我没有包含在内。如果你需要温习一下，让我们快速过一遍。因为我认为，任何能让我们更坚定的进一步方法，任何能触动你心灵的东西，都很重要。所以，记住要直接但不要严厉。
Practice before you step into a conversation. Keep your tone calm. Always, if you feel the need to yell, shout, walk away. Hold eye contact and own your note. Try and intentionally stop yourself from over-explaining or apologizing. This is a habit that is hard to break. It's somewhat built into our DNA to avoid conflict through appeasement. But apologizing or coming back or going back on your point can really undermine what you have to say.
在开始对话前先进行练习。保持语调平静。无论何时，如果你觉得有冲动想大喊大叫，那就走开。保持眼神交流，并为自己的观点负责。试着刻意阻止自己过度解释或道歉。这是一个很难改掉的习惯。通过顺从来避免冲突在某种程度上已经刻进了我们的DNA。但道歉、退让或收回你的观点，确实会削弱你想说的话。
The critical thing to remember is, it's not a bad thing to be assertive. It's not an ugly or a selfish thing. It's actually a huge sign of respect towards the person or people you are speaking to because it's saying, this is what I need. Can you do this for me or not? I want to have an honest relationship with you. I don't want to waste your time and I respect you enough to not try and conceal what I'm really after.
需要记住的关键一点是：坚定并不是一件坏事。它不是一件丑陋或自私的事情。它实际上是对你正在与之对话的人或人们的极大尊重，因为它是在说：“这就是我需要的。你能为我做到这一点吗？”我想与你建立真诚的关系。我不想浪费你的时间，而且我足够尊重你，不会试图掩饰我真正的诉求。
sometimes when I struggle with this because I definitely do in work situations, it's a big issue for me. I can be assertive in all other areas except for work. But I just remind myself, sometimes you have to be the asshole. Sometimes you have to be the asshole. And so be it. If they are going to judge you, that is okay. Their judgments, they mean a whole lot less than your happiness.
有时当我在这方面苦苦挣扎时——我在工作场合确实如此，这对我是个大问题。我在其他所有领域都能做到坚定，唯独在工作上不行——我只是提醒自己：有时候你必须当那个混蛋。有时候你必须当那个混蛋。那就这样吧。如果他们要评判你，那也没关系。他们的评判，其分量远不及你的快乐重要。
So I hope that you have learned something from. this episode. I hope that you can take these five tips I had for you today and integrate them. Even if it's just one, even if it's just one sentence that I said, I really meant it when I said being an assertive communicator unlocks so much in your life. And it is a practice. It is a skill. I think the first thing is we need to mentally get over the roadblock that being assertive means that we are being disrespectful. It's the complete opposite. And when you finally are, you realize it's kind of a strange epiphany like why wasn't I always doing this like gosh I've missed out on a lot by keeping my mouth shut but the good thing is the good news is it starts today and you can go
所以我希望你从这一集中学到了一些东西。我希望你能把今天分享给你的这五个建议融入生活中。哪怕只有一个，哪怕只是我说的一句话。当我说道“成为一个坚定的沟通者能为你的人生解锁无限可能”时，我是认真的。这是一种练习，是一种技能。我认为首要的事情是，我们需要在心理上克服这样一个路障：即坚定意味着我们不尊重他人。事实恰恰相反。当你终于做到这一点时，你会意识到这是一种奇怪的顿悟，心想：“我以前为什么不一直这样做呢？天哪，因为闭口不言我错失了好多。”但好消息是，这一切从今天开始，你可以带着这些技能、
forward with these skills with these habits with these tricks and tips and hopefully change how you really express what you want what you need what you deserve thank you so much for listening as always make sure that you are following us on instagram at that psychology podcast, we are always looking for new episode suggestions. You can DM me over there. Make sure to share this episode with a friend who might need it. And until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself, be assertive. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and
这些习惯、这些诀窍和建议继续前行，并有望改变你真正表达自己想要什么、需要什么、应得什么的方式。非常感谢大家的收听，一如既往，请确保在Instagram上关注我们：@thatpsychology podcast。我们一直在寻找新的节目选题，你可以在那边给我发私信。请务必将这期节目分享给可能需要它的朋友。直到下次，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温和一点，坚定自我。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身以及
building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam Jay and I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it, with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year.
在这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。这是iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方的TWA。在《回顾历史》播客中。对1979年来说，那是对我而言意义重大的一刻。84年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·杰伊，我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何在朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家的陪伴下挺过那段时光的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代一样。那是个疯狂的年份。
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
那是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾历史》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯主持的《艰难学习法》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起交流。有多少男人带着盔甲生活？这向世界发出了一个信号：你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
但这并不意味着因为你有这种能力，你就必须这么做。请在AHA Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习法》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Greg, a lesbian. Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·兰吉尼。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《被爱困住》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《被爱困住》播客。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。